cette chasse au four prête depuis 10 ans son
homme le plus dangereux avec jamais suivi
salut c'est Katie et nous sommes au jour 23 de
Riddick c'était la première fois que
je devais tirer avec le gros
fusil de sniper mais j'aurais en quelque sorte souhaité que nous  aurait
pu utiliser des tours complets parce qu'ils étaient un
bébé quart de tour et ils n'étaient pas
si bruyants mais c'était très amusant juste
descendre j'ai une petite blessure une telle
fille
c'est comme un acteur blessé comme si ce n'était pas
du pistolet malheureusement c'est  du
pack de micros je me suis cogné le tibia dessus maintenant tu
vas voir ce que j'appelle le gros
chien c'est le pistolet de Diaz le seul qui est
assez gros pour le porter est
dave bautista et c'est énorme
imaginez-moi venir sauver
Riddick  c'est seulement comme une femme vraiment forte
peut faire regarder mon bras